hello everyone and welcome to Simply
learn today we take you to the world of
large language models where you will
witness The Clash of the two titles Chad
GPT the one standing under the Limelight
for so long with the title as the
unbeaten llm to date or is it
unprecedented one with the Fresh Blades
that claim to be phenomenal compared to
older Legends join us on our YouTube
channel as we Deep dive and unravel one
mystery at a time and decide which one
amongst the two Stands Tall and proud so
without any further delay let's get
started and if these are the type of
videos you'd like to watch hit that
subscribe button and the bell icon not
to miss any future updates on our
channel so that's all for the agenda
guys let's now jump onto our topic but
before that if you want to upskill
yourself master artificial intelligence
and machine learning skills and land
your dream job or grow in your career
then you must explore simply learns
cohort of various artificial
intelligence and machine learning
programs simply learn offers
certification and post-graduate programs
in collaboration with leading
universities like IIT kpur Purdue and
Caltech for example through our Ai and
ml postgraduate program you will gain
knowledge Work Ready expertise in skills
like generative AI prompt engineering
explainable AI machine learning
algorithms and over dozens of others
that's not all you'll also get
opportunity to work on multiple projects
and learn from industry experts in top
tier product companies and academicians
from top universities after completing
these courses thousands of Learners have
transitioned into an artificial
intelligence and machine learning
engineer role as fresher or moved onto a
higher paying job and profile if you are
passionate about making your career in
this field then make sure to check out
the link in the pin comment and
description box to find an artificial
intelligence and machine learning
program that feds your experience and
areas of Interest versions of Google
Gemini has been watching watching
silently making notes of the benchmarks
set by CH GPT and waiting for an
opportunity to strike and when it did it
Unleashed a set of impressive features
and functionalities that shocked the
world making a clear statement saying it
was a time for Google to shine Google
released three variants of Gemini as a
successor to its already established
Palm tool the three variants are Gemini
Ultra Gemini Pro and Gemini Nano Gemini
Nano is the most efficient ient and
designed for portable devices like
mobile devices variables and tablets
this light version is currently
operational in latest pixel devices next
is the Gemini Pro it is considered the
best version of Gemini for scaling
across various task such as chat Bots
virtual assistance and content
generation this model is the backbone of
Bard it is accessible to developers and
Enterprise customers through Google
generative AI studio in Google Google
Cloud starting in December
2023 lastly let's address the elephant
in the room Gemini's Ultra which is
designed for complex scientific research
extensive Big Data analysis and realtime
assistance and medical assistance like
drug recovery task this most potent
version is not yet available for public
use Google announced its release in the
early 20124 but a specific date hasn't
been announced yet we already know Char
gbt and knowing who Gemini is and what
it's capable of let's proceed with a
head-to-head comparison of Gemini
against the current rigning champion
that's Chad GPT based on some critical
parameters starting with the
availability availability starting with
the fundamentals is recognitions
real-time visual analysis and text
recognition both chat GPT and Gemini
were tested to their full potential and
the results were favorable towards
Gemini Gemini employs the chain of
thoughts while chj relies on five shs
technique this could impact their final
scores Gemini outperformed chat GPT with
30 out of 32 academic benchmarks
including 10 out of 12 popular text and
reasoning benchmarks nine of nine
understanding benchmarks six of six
video understanding benchmarks and five
of five speech recognition and
translation benchmarks overall Gemini I
scored 90% surpassing Chad gbt at
86.4% now let's proceed with the a of
use a of use regarding real-time
operational functionality and simplicity
to address the a of use chat GPT stands
Paramount among the two chat GPT
currently follows text based prompts
giving us one-on-one communication
experience on the other hand Gemini is
currently working on simplifying things
and minimizing complexity for now it's a
work in progress next ahead we have in
integration with other services
integration with other services is a
critical point of introducing the large
language models with natural language
processing is to enhance the
productivity and save time this can
include processing speed the ability to
integrate adapt synchronized with
plugins tools and Frameworks currently
chat GPT takes a lead here it can
integrate with third party tools and
plugins enhancing productivity in
contrast gemni is a right behind charity
in the race currently Gemini has limited
integration options next we have
accessibility Tools in our docket of
differences between the two AI Giants
accessibility tools when it comes to
accessibility chat GPT is equipped with
an array of accessibility features such
as text to speech text to text
functionalities ensuring a more
inclusive experience for users with
diverse abilities while Gemini has not
been officially launched Google's robers
dedic ation to accessibility strongly
indicates that it will integrate a range
of accessibility tools to enhance user
experience upon its
release now the last parameter in the
differences but not the least that is
operational cost cost of Charity extends
free access with restricted features
catering to users on a budget unlocking
a more comprehensive suit of tools
features and functionality becomes
possible through paid plans which are
focused on keeping them affordable on
the contrary the specific pricing
information for Gemini remains
undisclosed at this point however it is
anticipated to adopt a pricing structure
akin to the other Google AI products
this could involve a free toer access
with fundamental features and tiered
paid plans providing access to more
advanced functionalities and that wraps
the head-on-head comparison and Gemini
Google's AI counterpart to chat gbt
which engages in robust competition
demonstrating a superior performance in
Benchmark and harboring the potential to
redefine the landscape of language
models although Chad GPT currently holds
an accessibility Advantage Gemini
eminent launch aspires to democratize
Advanced AI offering diverse model
tailored to a spectrum of needs with its
plans and effort to develop seamless
integration capabilities Gemini expected
to emerge as a favored AI solution for
developers and businesses hinting at a
potential paradigm shift in AI Supremacy
and with that guys we have reached to
the end of the session on open AI chat
GP versus Google Gemini should you need
assistance with your doubt files and
other resources used in this session
please let us know in the comment
section below and our team of experts
will be happy to help you as soon as
possible until next time thank you and
keep learning stay tuned for more from
Simply learn stay staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here